meaning a lot of times it seems to women
that they are doing more for the men
than the men are doing for them and it's
because they don't count the amount of
effort it has taken men to get to the
point where we want to select them and a
lot of times what what you'll see in
wives is they'll they'll think they're
doing more CU maybe they're cooking for
their husband three days a week maybe
they're cleaning the house maybe they're
watching the kids but they don't count
the effort it took him to build the life
that you're in and my question to her is
what more effort could he put in equally
I mean he he's handsome he's successful
he's wealthy the grass is not going to
be green around the other side I don't
know what this woman thinks is on the
other side as a 40-some year old single
mother